hi there steve kaufman
um i lost a week in my 90 day challenge
i had visitors from sweden and um
basically i spent the last week with
them i hardly had a chance to listen to
any polish or read any polish
it doesn't matter i know that i won't
really
lose much when i go back to it i'll
recover what i had and probably be
stronger
than ever remember my video on
interleaving leaving something alone
going back to it in fact you learn
better
what i want to talk about today is
exercise and language learning now we
know that learning languages
is good for your brain it improves your
cognitive abilities staves up dementia
all this good stuff
but a lot of my um
language learning takes place while i'm
physically exercising
uh and i was thinking you know maybe our
90-day challenge should be you know walk
a half hour a day and listen for half an
hour or you know because i'm
on my stepper reading my ipad i run
while listening to audio uh you know my
languages
when i have a few hand weights and stuff
downstairs and i i get my ipad or at
least my iphone or or um
ipod and bluetooth it to a speaker
and then i'm listening to my polish as
i'm exercising so i think the idea of
tying exercise to language learning has
all kinds of benefits it
if it may get you to do more exercise
like even walking
it also enables you to find time to do
the listening
and if you're good if you're good on a
stepper or that kind of you have access
to that kind of of exercise you know
treadmill you can actually be reading
say as i do my i link on my ipad uh
while exercising so the theme here is
exercise and language learning let's
combine the two and continue with your
90 day challenge i will bye for now